[Musique]
nous vous accueillons aujourd'hui c'est
le 5 octobre presque le 5 octobre en
asie et le 4 octobre à l'heure de
montréal en ce moment a eu nous reste
encore presque 44 minutes et 50 secondes
où ça doit vite avant l'heure du midi
ici à montréal et autour de la table on
a bien sûr nos coéquipiers de
différentes sections de radio canada
international qui se joignent à cette
émission en direct alors on saluerait
mandé marteau bonjourbonjour samir ben
jaffar bonjour tout le monde
félicitations merci d'être venu vous
êtes de la section toujours d'appel
grains de visiteurs qui viennent
d'amérique
marie-jo ben ça va ça ce n'est pas
possible
avez vous quelque chose à ajouter c'est
la confirmation vous êtes à radio canada
international la grande sophie la plus
importante le français alors écouter
aujourd'hui bien mais blague là dessus
vous et adel ali ne le nom ne vous
retenez pas je commence seulement qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de blagues
ok très bien ajouté cette semaine
n'avait aucune idée du sujet encore oui
comme d'habitude cette idée non vraiment
si c'est lié à l'actualité je sais pas
ça peut être bien les jo mais là je
regarde n'a évité ce soit et je ne
reconnais pas donc ça va on a b que nos
auditeurs en asie aux aussi voit cette
séquence et qu'il est en asie c'est ça
sinon je vous envoie des fausses pistes
où le talent et ce alors on regarde la
vidéo no 5 images et vous des tenter de
déterminer le sujet et il faut y aller
et faut être précis cette semaine
j'accepte pas les généralités comme les
semaines précédentes
voici premières images j'ai inscrit
jusqu'à l'est de montréal
c'est très bonnes scènes d'automne à
montréal présenté par des français
au vert quelque chose de vert
habitations verte peut être une bonne
piste je trouve ça très long corridor
énergétique saynètes familier dans
l'ouest pour le roller des sables
bitumineux alors qu'est ce qui se
dessine présentement images numéro 4 à
l'émission c'est pas mal répandu la
pollution changements politiques
changement climatique
oui voilà oui à hackney dans le contexte
de dans les élections exactement ouais
ouais ouais voilà mes écoutes c'est ça
hein élections moi au départ pour moi
c'était un sujet électoral finalement en
aidant les journalistes vous êtes
finalement on est dedans mais je ne sais
pas si l'environnement est vraiment au
coeur du débat électoral à ce moment on
sait qu'il ya une grosse manifestation
notamment à montréal la semaine dernière
c'était comme ça dans plusieurs grandes
capitales du monde entier
on n'est pas exceptionnel ce sujet là
mais cette manifestation évidemment
coïncidé avec la campagne électorale au
canada qui va se terminer le 21 par un
gagnant aigle et le passage c'est vrai
donc ça c'était signé dans les médias
internationaux également cette présence
et celle en juillet selon jeu électoral
c'est très générationnel est aussi très
très régional c'est l'aspect de la chose
régionaliser par rapport à greta d'une
barque on a eu une greta canadienne on
arrive la fille de david suzuki qui a
parlé à rio en 92
on connaît des précurseurs ici sauf qu'à
l'époque il y avait exactement il n'y
avait pas les bâtons cargo
les embarcations en carbone qui
traversait l'atlantique donc vous avez
des idées formidables à développer bien
sûr la carte de reportage est
aujourd'hui bien sûr à cette émission
on y va avec le magicien j'ai presque
envie de j'ai presque l'impression
d'entendre des assignations à le
développer le jeu ne donne pas les ordis
il n'y a pas de danger suggestions
complexe qui la soupçonne d'avoir mené
des actions
j'avais pas lu mais mélanie bon premier
tour de la grosse boule à l'émission il
y aura trois tours à l'émission chaque
fois qu à la boule tourner vous risquez
de perdre vos boules voulait garder ou
l'égard des semboules a permis sur
fantastic 20 brûle pour ce premier je
vois si on affiche la question tout le
monde joue même à l'extérieur du studio
en asie notamment
alors voici quel est le nom exact du
ministère canadien de l'environnement
vous écrivez des articles il faut bien
rentrer
me catherine glon alors c'est quoi son
ministre alors est-ce que c'est à
environnement canada
est ce que ces bébés changement
climatique canada est ce que c'est c'est
nature et environnement canada ou des
est-ce que c'est aucune de ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses parce que vous
dire où je dirais environnement et
changement climatique
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait aucune série
c'est la même joie pour moi qu'est-ce
que vous mêmes choix des l'aider ça a
été longtemps un environnement canada
n'a aucune de ces réponses auxquelles de
ce qu'est ce que vous diriez vous a et b
je pense c'est un ep même nom c'est à
dire que c'est exactement c'est ça le
vrai d'accord ça lui aussi très proches
dans des cas un changement non
finalement déniché croix basque
environnement canada c'est le service
métérologique ça
donc vous avez gardé toutes vos boules
félicitations ces deux pour qu'il sait
vraiment ce ces jeux vous dire c'est pas
osé titrer vous sur l'environnement et
les changements climatiques
c'est ce à quoi j'ai vu ça à paraître
changement climatique je vois ça fait
depuis 4-5
oui pour vous dire mais j'ai ce niveau
qu'est ce que c'est que ça avec lui avec
le avec les libéraux comptent y sont
arrivés au pouvoir dont ils ont adopté
cette appellation visiblement ya pas de
climato sceptiques ou sein du
gouvernement oui ici la marche larmes
ouais c'est ça il fait ça prend
plusieurs arguments pour une élection m
on en parlera commence à plusieurs
avions pour une élection
non parce que au dernier débat électoral
le chef conservateur ils sont des prix à
au chef libéral justin trudeau pour lui
signifier que pour un libre pour un pour
quelqu'un qui qui est un pro
environnement et qui prend deux avions
pendant ce temps d'une élection pour
pour sa campagne électorale a été
envoyée ou cissé il y en a une pour vous
et l'eau pour vous continuez vos côtés
de vos canaux c'était un deux en un sauf
que lui il a répondu qu'il avait quand
même corriger ces crédits carbone mais
l'on vérifie que l'équipe de
vérification de radio canada ils ont
fait une vérif ils ont trouvé que même
avec deux avions
ils ont fait à peu près les mêmes pneus
même parcelle n'est pas de la distance
qui est pas réalisons parcours à peu
près les mêmes distances les essais des
deux animateurs qui propulsa l'avion oui
là aussi le poids des journées c'est
plus léger de chez les libéraux les
journalistes paient moins pour être sur
l'avion du conservateur et toi ça va
exactement mais ils ont un horizon fait
une offre c'est un exemple ils ont
proposé un rabais mais ce qui est bien
c'est que les journalistes paient leur
place
ça rajoute un peu à l'indépendance du
journal saxo option au canada
contrairement à ce qui se passe ailleurs
alors voici maintenant je voulais juste
vous demandez vous rappeler que vous
parlez du débat électoral le premier
débat électoral qui avait lui quel jour
exactement le mercredi de cette semaine
de cette semaine la tva à leurs alliés
en français en français c'est être pris
parce qu'il y en a eu un autre en
anglais le mot klein citytv à toronto et
auquel le premier ministre sortant n'a
pas assisté par me lâche au space usage
de loi lui l'a choisi les navetteurs qui
avait attaqué naviguer non accompagnés
qui n'a pas été invitée sinon des autres
ils étaient présents bon c'est en fait
coûté
oui parce que c'est un peu comme moi
j'ai raté ses débuts le prochain des
boutiques le sont le lundi 7 anglais de
7h à
on va commencer de cette époque c'était
maintenance et autres c'est celui du
rendu vendredi prochain je le dis je
différencie des élections fédérales
canadiennes où il veut suivre le débat
des chefs en direct lundi en anglais
avec traduction en français
ce n est point ca il y aura il y aura d
autres langues aussi aura chinois aussi
arabes pour ceux qui veulent suivre sur
notre site internet aussi chinois dans
calendar est exactement et en arabe ce
sera de la tradition simultanée aussi en
langue des signes
c'est ce que j'ai pu le lire parce que
selon ce que j'ai dit tout le temps
qu'on a pris pour expliquer ce résultat
nos publicités électorales
ça aurait été plus limpides on va les
faire d'autres invités sky de la semaine
pour parler du sujet au coeur de nos
préoccupations de parler de la nouvelle
énergie des questions environnementales
dans le débat électoral
est ce vrai ce que si c'est vrai ou
c'est aux faits en ce début avril avec
cette histoire là normand mousseau du
département de physique université de
montréal et les spécialistes de
l'énergie des ressources naturelles ou
si directeur académique de l'institut de
l'énergie droitier à l'école
polytechnique de montréal professeur
bonjour alors un professeur on va
expliquer à nos amis ici que ce n'est
pas la première fois que vous intéresser
à la question de la politique des débats
électoraux concernant à l'environnement
vous aviez déjà je pense lancer une
initiative au moyen d'un an et demi
c'était en prévision des élections au
québec et je pense qu on a même une
petite vidéo a présenté pendant que vous
nous bright rappellerez ces moments ses
premiers moments que en politique faut
premier moment c'est notre vidéo numéro
3 aujourd'hui
et puis vous faisiez ça pour faire des
recommandations aux politiciens ou pour
encadrer le débat quel était votre
approche exactement
[Musique]
avec les partis politiques on retrouve à
table propose des solutions de
transformation de gouvernants auraient
sorti avant toute l'année avant les
élections au québec
pour ceux qui l'ont raté voici des
images du débat électoral de mercredi en
français là on va présenter vos images à
vous de il ya quelques temps plusieurs
mois l'an dernier lorsque y avait encore
une campagne électorale
est ce qu'à ce moment alors on sentait
que la population les électeurs étaient
plus intéressés aux questions
environnementales ou c'est un sujet qui
évolue lentement plus lentement
peut-être qu'on aura par exemple donnez
nous un peu de perspective sur la
sensibilité des électeurs par rapport à
l'environnement
depuis quelques temps une manifestation
très importante à montréal je ne sais
pas si c'était vraiment la plus
importante du oui andrieu 500 mille 5000
personnes selon les organisateurs 300
déclaré porte avec ses du monde et a
fait une vidéo est tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est sur youtube
allez voir ça ouais puis s'étant
accélérée donc on marche accélérée plus
rapidement faire avancer les choses plus
rapidement j'imagine aussi et puis en
tout cas c'était impressionnant parce
que moi j'ai vu ça z'ont sur le plancher
des vaches
mais vu de haut on s'aperçoit à quel
point il
il y avait du monde y avait des jeunes
surtout les jeunes parce que ce jour là
aussi à montréal
le stationnement des jeunes parce que
j'ai vu des chronos ne fait pas de l'ag
qui sont les bouclages jeudi il ya
beaucoup de gens parce que parce que ce
jour-là la commission la commission
scolaire de montréal
elle avait lavé dans une journée
pédagogique donc c'était une occasion
aussi de faire sortir les gens qui sont
alors là on a un contexte tout à fait
précis cessé de c'est-à-dire eu une
mouvement international qui vient avoir
un impact des échos dans une campagne
fédérale électorale
est-ce que ça amplifie les choses
réellement ne peux pas vous parler avec
l'europe
au canada on a quand même des partis dès
le départ qu'on aime ou on est du pont
largement alors que le roi dans la
plupart des pays a eu un contact est
établi que la nuit ses désirs ils n'ont
encore plus comme avant c'est là la
grande on connaît au canada convoyeurs
et pourquoi justement il ya cette
différence est ce qu on est moins
conscients à propos de l'environnement
au canada
est ce que c'est parce que le territoire
est plus grand on se déplace plus il ya
moins de transports en commun
comment on explique ça beaucoup plus
grande au débat a mérité donc on a
importé un peu la navy très glissante
pourtant vraiment le combat comme un à
trois on a un pays qu'il ya eu des
progrès en attendant la production pour
leur économie
il ya donc province ne produisent aucun
hydrocarbure donc le commentaire
de diderot et carbonisé en termes de
production d'énergie et les crises et le
québec aussi dans beaucoup de provinces
l'enjeu est vraiment dans un bouchon
vous disiez vous avez dit quelque chose
un peu plus tôt ou sur lequel j'aimerais
revenir quand vous parlez au niveau
cérébral au niveau intellectuel ou
niveau carrément théorique s'est
fortement accepté sait comment ça se
déclinent chez les gens que là ça ne
passe pas et j'ai l'impression aussi que
cette déclinaison ses dents à mesure on
va le faire oui mais faut pas que ça me
choque pas que ça coûte 10 où il ya
beaucoup cet aspect là aussi chez celle
le canadien terrier vote
la marathon a qualifié une attaque n'a
pas exemple allemagne on voit souvent
l'allemagne comme un mouvement de
transition est largement basée sur
mouvements incluent pierre donc la
période initiale au début des années 80
avec le statut de favori sur nous on
s'exile à 2 centimes à lui dans une
problématique système beaucoup plus
complète pour les allemands mais c'est
parce qu'on a réussi à part au canada
n'a pas rendu plus complet l'action qui
m'attirait examen j'ai passé mon geste à
moi tout seul n'a pas d'impact sur les
enfants qui naissent et puis je veux
police en ingouchie à court moyen ou
long terme pour moi à 13 et 15
je me dis par la série de 1950 qui est
spécifique au québec les camions parce
que monsieur chirac
au québec c'est là où on vendait le plus
grand nombre de camions tandis que dans
l'ensemble du canada
oui mais lui parler du québec tant qu'il
était là exact mais en fait il faut dire
que ça c'est nouveau au québec on que
les gros camions 25-20 plus mais ça a
commencé dans l'ouest canadien
donc mangé une question à monsieur
mousseau donc on a vu le vendredi
dernier le 27 on a vu cinq cent mille
personnes dans les rues de montréal
pourquoi ça se transforme pas dans les
urnes pas pourquoi ça ne va pas dans les
gens pourquoi ça ne se transforme pas en
une question de lyon comme on l'appelle
pourquoi est ce que c'est c'est à cause
des partis politiques à part le parti
vert qui est clairement var qui ne
veulent pas prendre cette cette
problématique comme prioritaire ou si
c'est quoi le but alors ils vont choisir
leurs thèmes mais on préfère réduire le
peut pas mathématique on ne peut être
pris à d'autres villes il dit
pour lui on est à fond en terme de recul
on de temps des fêtes main et mignot
version de la qualité d'allié ratons la
santé qui coûte au pays à tous les
niveaux
les personnes lui ali fiables ont par
exemple pas déverser les plus jeunes on
ne vieillit très dangereux l' abus
dangereux ont résonné complètement du je
suis vraiment pour moi le gros problème
un travail qu'on apportait et au canada
puis dans d'autres pays on commence à
taper fort qu'ont aussi raté un peu
d'astuce mandat votre pays ou si les
premières versions qu'on a fait de ces
carbonisé l'électricité cpsl on appelle
deux trois compagnies qui font des lexus
t on a vu fermer votre nous avons fait
une centrale au gaz ou une ont cassé des
indiennes ça va marcher
cela touche pas le petit des lifts one
et on arrive là par exemple en
angleterre on s'aperçoit c'est la preuve
jusqu'à présent on ne sait pas combien
se tourner maintenant au canada a vu son
carbone à 80% avec lui il faut coucher
du feutre fait qu'il faut lui
directement et qu'il se laissait cette
heure mais les voitures transportent de
l'habitation canada le peuplement parler
d'une consommation encore à coxyde et au
canada le mans responsables sont gazés à
faire et puis tout simplement les
employés dans leur côté le professeur
mouchot j'aimerais qu'on revienne
directement dans la campagne électorale
et les propos des différents politiciens
parlons disons de de la mine naturelle
de la nature le parti vert elizabeth may
la chef du parti qui est là depuis des
années qui a une couple d'années disait
qu'elle voulait sans le parti voulait
remettre les rênes du parti à quelqu'un
d'autre
elle fait campagne en ce moment
plusieurs disent qu'elle n'a pas ne
raisonne pas dans les oreilles de la
jeunesse de ces de cette génération plus
jeune génération qui est la plus
intéressée par les questions de
protection de l'environnement
est ce que moi je la regarde et je vous
me posez la question qu'est ce qu'elle a
dit durant cette campagne qui fait que
l'environnement est maintenant est la
miss ao devant j'entends pas j'entends
des questions sur l'avortement j'entends
des réactions à d'autres politiques
d'autres partis et je ne l'entends pas l
eau devant menant une campagne où elle
est là un message environnemental clair
et net
la compo pétrole il a maintenant dix
raffineries canadiennes et que tous les
temps sont donnés dans les voitures
doivent vivre canada et démocratique il
ya un peu un problématique on avance est
grande mais les mesures pour lui
pardonner par exemple on promet de
régions de france en portant les
émissions de gaz est fatale c'est de
mettre en commun qui proposait pour nous
amener la fin de l'entente
autre question tourne à table est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on voit des politiciens
qui essaye de ménager la chèvre et le
chou comme monsieur 30 jours c'est ce
qu'on fait alors lorsque lors de porcs
ont fait clair ne pas trop déplaire de
l'environnement il faut à la fois
annoncer qu'on va épauler en partie
c'est vraiment bon ce soir mousseau est
ce que vous auriez une prédiction quant
à je suis l'actualité européenne depuis
des années c'est normal on s'intéresse
tout c'est ce qui se passe de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique en jour nous venons
de ce serait une belle région du monde
il ya des dizaines ou de centaines ça
dépend des cartes et puis je qui
vos véhicules si c'est ça mais vous vous
avez vu que en allemagne alors quand
j'entends parler du parti vert qui est
une donnée importante en politique
européenne
moi je rêve toujours d'un monde plus
équilibré où il n'y a pas de partie
finalement deux grands partis d'un et
c'est un peu ce qui se passe au canada
en ce moment est-ce que c'est
folklorique voter pour le parti vert
encore en ce moment je sais où c'est ça
devient ça va devenir sérieux dans un
système uninominal à un tour
le nouveau toit c'est ça bon bah écoutez
professeur monsieur on va vous laisser
retourner à vos éprouvette je sais que
certains scientifiques c'est bien de
voir quelqu'un qui qui est d'un monde
disons au niveau de la science de
s'intéresser à la question politique aux
impacts politiques de tout ça merci
beaucoup professeur mousseau je suis moi
dans ma bouche ou du département de
physique alliance tellement rien le
spécialiste de l'énergie des ressources
naturelles est aussi directeur du fameux
institut de l'énergie 3 thiais à l'école
polytechnique de montréal
je vais dire encore ce mot que j'adore
je n'ai pas dit mais le sein du beau
temps de le dire c'est fini alors qu'on
vient de vous la perle pour le deuxième
tour de la grosse boule c'est ça vous
avez gardé toutes vos premières brulin
ball va la deuxième question la fiche a
annoncé ses comptes seront pas heureux
ce soir fait qui a été à 0 ici dans le
passé vous je passe comment
écoutez c'est très rare comme phénomène
alors voici en quelle année le ministère
canadien de l'environnement est il né
les questions de base 1 messieurs ce
qu'on vérifie les connaissances de base
des journalistes en général avant d
embaucher
depuis avec moi j'ai vu cette
information non mais je peux faire de
m'en souvenir
ok ça répond pas à la question mais ça
nous donnerait à 70,70 1970 d'ailleurs
quelle année 207 c'est après la
révolution tranquille certains bruits de
15 à 70 ans et en pleine guerre aucun
indice ne savait pas en 1907
j'imagine que c'était pas non je dis
1906 1907
ça s'appelait comme sami 5
environnements où servait les
prérogatives entre 1970 d'accord enfin
pour moi ou moi jls est un trait 40 et
70 mais pour faire différent samuel avec
40 personnes a dit 1990 s'est passé pas
ça c'est bien ce n'était pas la bonne
réponse
on affiche la bonne réponse merci
beaucoup donc on pouvait parler d'accord
allait mais vous pouvez partager
alors ça c'est 1970 ce que je trouvais
très intéressant c'était le papa de
justin trudeau qui était alors chef du
parti libéral et chaque canadien dominé
les milices c'était quelques années
après il avait dit on s'occupe pas des
chambres à coucher week-end 12 cette
année c'est dans la récession et a cédé
l'omnibus
comme il ne s'occupait pas des jambes à
coucher il avait le temps de s'occuper
d'autre chose écoutez
ceux qui s'intéressent toujours
questions politiques doivent savoir que
radio canada international on a un
anglais spéciale qui s'appelle élections
2019 pour ceux qui veulent savoir
comment voter
on vous dit comment voter qui vont des
on vous dit également pour qui voter
voici une autre vidéo numéro 6 donc
c'est un des choix éclairés comme en
voit maintenant la formule n'écoutez pas
la propagande
voici alors c'est les archives sur le
même sujet quel sens elle est invitée
bah oui l'émission tu aimes tant qu'à ça
c'est vraiment je pense oui
première annonce vraiment ça défile
alors je pense qu'on a eu huit sujet
cette semaine des taxes sur les robots
pour le parti vert
ouais c'est ça que c'est pour ça qu'il
est qui parle pas trop de
d'environnement d'où et puis ça c'est
une question qu'on soulevé au début des
élections ça c'est vraiment le bloc
fesses de citoyenneté qui dont il a
hérité c'est ça voilà il est en
processus de révocation du conseil
ça prend 6 à 8 mois je pense pour
évoquer ses insolites américaine
michaëlle jean a été la même situation
moment donné quand on été nommé
gouverneur général sauf qu'elle est
conservateur à l'époque il avait
reproché d'avoir la double citoyenneté
française est aussi reproché à l'ancien
ministre de l'environnement me suis dit
aux muscles à tabac se moquer mais le
hip hop pour nous pour ceux qui nous
suivent donc il ya une condition pour
être 1er mai premier ministre il faut
avoir une citoyenneté canadienne et
exclusive c'est ça je ne crois pas et
bien c'est politiquement se policer plus
politiquement parce que c'est dans son
cas il est américain et canadien on se
dit bon quand il veut négocier des
accords avec en notre nom est ce qu'il
va aussi avoir le chapeau américain
donc c'est un problème politique plus
que l'égal sans problème de perception
assez bien et parce qu'ils y passent
cadets ya des pays où c'est vraiment par
exemple
cependant je sais que pour être
président il faut être il faut avoir la
citoyenneté d'origine pas acquis il faut
que même le conjoint ou la conjointe et
dix années a au minimum 10 ans qu'est-ce
que tu t'intéresses tellement dit sur la
perception
parce qu'en ce moment le parti
conservateur adopte un ton dans la
campagne qui ressemble un peu aux
publicités américaines sous la main
centre est dégradante pour les autres
participent aussi au pays derrière
justement vous pour être président il
faut être né aux états unis
on ne recule pas un autre président
américain
si on est à kielce grande qui a été
reçue qui a acquis la citoyenneté non
adjani xing par exemple quel chef du npd
il est né au canada
il est né au canada ok mais si ce
faisant qu'il est quelqu'un est né au
japon par exemple il ya au canada et il
a sa citoyenneté pour être ministre
regardez simplement à l'époque où j'ai
rejoint par mms a c'est un système
fonctionne horrifique mais où jal
losange qui a été député pendant très
longtemps ministre libéral en colombie
britannique mais dans le gouvernement
canadien aurait pu s'il avait voulu
c'est tout à fait le genre qu'il parlait
pourtant lui né en inde 20 bon alors
barre des inclusions réellement là au
niveau du noyau poste on est prêts pour
la dernière question je voulais juste
qu'on appelle les scores personne
n'avait la mauvaise mauvaise réponse
rooney lui les plus haut parce qu'elle
lui les bonnes réponses à la dernière
levée ou non d'une arme on est à 70 me
[Musique]
50 points maintenant cinq ans ce soir
c'est tout ce que vous avez pas les
garder aussi vous pourriez dégâts il est
compétitif
invité à l'émission
alors voici la dernière question s'est
produit dans la pétition
l'écho a oui faut que vous ayez que fond
la question salut c'est que on à l'égard
de gardes côtiers canadiens qui se veut
aussi une responsabilité
environnementale même s'ils font pas
partie du ministère de l'environnement
ils sont partis du ministère attendez
que je trouve quelque chose passion
c'est non mais c'est aussi un bon mais
des fois il ya des dégâts ya des navires
qui perdent du mazout ou à ya autre
chose qui se produit qui peut causer des
problèmes à l'environnement ils ont la
surveillance de la responsable
surveillance des côtes
alors quand vous parlez de côtes n'ont
donc plus au nord sur l'océan
on sait donc pacifique atlantique et en
partie participe des trois océans canada
alors l'écho canadienne s'étale sur
combien de milliers de kilomètres et des
militants mais il n'y a pas d'aidé alors
il faut vraiment est ce que ces deux
fois la distance entre la terre et la
lune dans le total des kilomètres de
côtes faut couvrir parce que c'est 4
fois la distance entre la terre et la
station spatiale internationale ssi son
nom presque cessé huit fois la distance
du tour de la terre alors quatre fois la
distance entre la station spatiale
internationale et à 400 km de côtes
mais si son club actuellement non les
garde côtes ont la responsabilité de
combien de milliers de kilomètres c'est
l'équivalent de 2,4 fois la distance
entre la terre et la station ne s'est
pas beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup ses 1600
km ans c'est sa dette abyssale et
l'instinct du tueur de la terre alors
dites-moi si 44 alors raymond tissait
vous vous dites quoi samir sas et c'est
le sait où le avec la lune c'est clair
que non c'est là que non vraiment qu'ils
ont agi va faire les petits les petits
ruisseaux voit ce que vous conte
alors on s'en bat sauf deux merci parce
que 44 mille fois huit dans ses beaux
mls est remonté de calcul il faut
choisir
bah nord 1400 km c'est sympa et coutts
et c'est alors dépasser 8 fois la
distance du tour de la terre oui marie
moi je vais faire dix anciens juste pour
m'amuser
est ce qu'un pas ah ah ah
deux fois la distance entre la terre et
la lune saluant la distance moyenne
entre la terre et la lune ses 346 milles
qui donne les moyens parce que c'est bon
ça se promène beaucoup cette lune et
mais ce serait sa loi sam est la bonne
réponse c'est huit fois la distance du
taux d'avant tour de la terre ses
quarante mille kilomètres dont 243 mais
l'arrêt darré mètres de la côte depuis
qu'il faut surveiller
alors quand vous disions dans combien ça
fait 243 milles 42 le ctc est ce que
cette perception j'aurais jamais pensé à
ceux qui la distance entre la terre et
la station spatiale c'est seulement oui
parce qu'on avait aussi coupé 17 ans qui
vient de regagner aujourd'hui sa mise en
jeu
c'est là notre connaissance qu'il faut
que je me tienne ça moi je détestais les
professeurs qui avaient qui faisait un
examen le vendredi c'est pour la faire
oui la tenue et je le faire seulement là
je me venge après toutes ces années
moi j'avais un petit cadeau que je
voulais vous faire une belle et si vous
avez parlé de cette perle
on a de quoi c'est que on était à la
maison et on avait notre ce clash et là
on sort mon mari va porter les trucs
dans la voiture pour améliorer ce cash
et là il ya trois jeunes filles sont là
et qui ramasse ce que nous on va aller
porter alors on essaie de leur donner
mais là encore des trois jeunes filles
et là je leur demande
vous êtes originaire de classe qu'ils
vont à l'école du quartier unis
béninoise unis de la côte d'ivoire
elodie vietnam
alors je dis alors jeune fille quitte
ivoirienne didier drogba tu connais elle
me répond je parle pas la langue la côte
d'ivoire l'habit noir la regarde il dit
la voyant dans certains joueurs de
soccer originaire de la côte d'ivoire
alors ça m'a fait rire mais c'est pour
montrer que au québec c'est déjà acquis
que les gens ce sont des gens qui sont
venus s'installer ici x en est qui
fréquentent cette école qui est à deux
pas de chez moi
on a tout juste le temps pour la mise en
début de semaine je répond par oui ou
par non seulement à vos questions sont
brillantes
la suisse est liée aux élections oui
parfait deux avions c'est pas un orient
annonce est le débat non mais c'était
avant le débat à à savoir c'est un beau
rebond des dépenses à l'examen avant
qu'on présentait que ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est un homme sensé deux
hommes en fait ces deux
ouais deux hommes est-ce que ça par
rapport à 2005 avec le fameux à
l'hôpital et oui quand tu as dit deux
ans alors on à la semaine pour marisa
les sept îles a rien turban bleu oui
exactement
je voulais je m'entendais ce qu'il le
prenne il le met dans le débat au québec
mais finalement j'ai tourné que le son
avait l'air extrêmement bon oui on
attendait tous très bien et je me suis
demandé est-ce que c'était organisé ou
quoi le monsieur doom à jay nixon qui
est le leader du parti l'akp npd vous
pourriez pas emmener votre turban avec
seriez plus canadien de rihanna plus
canadiens quelque chose du genre le
messie je lui ai répondu je suis
canadien et je n'ai pas c'est comme ça
que ça se sont faits au canada et il ya
beaucoup qui ont lié sa à la loi 21 mai
puis mais le premier du cabba qu'il a
dit là il a vraiment il a dénoncé
l'attitude du monsieur donc pour partie
sur ses façades et la personne d d'idées
qui tient son ag monthey pour vous c'est
ça donc on n'a pas eu ça s'est bien
terminé soit se termine bien et il ya
une morale pour ceux que ça intéresse
c'est sur notre site web radio canada
c'est ici l'histoire se poursuit
est-ce qu'ils avaient autre chose a
ajouté oui absolument c'est très
important j'ai reçu un mémo du patron
connaissait et on en parle souvent du
patron solution alors sérieusement on a
une vidéo à vous présenter concernant la
la balado diffusion à radio canada
ouais très important d'en parler parce
que ça marche très fort donc on parle d
un familièrement alors ce radio canada
international
vous allez trouver un onglet quelque
part on descend sur la page un petit peu
on va voir quelque chose ça va être
marquée voilà c'est fait abonnez vous
vous pouvez vous abonner
ça coûte rien tout est gratuit bien sûr
puisqu'on est un service utilisé sur se
rendre au lieu d'écouter les émissions
je n'ai pas besoin de venir sur le site
vous allez automatiquement avoir sa via
votre application à nouveau les
entrevues 0 kg dans le métro il ya une
connexion web faut aller là ça peut
faire sur apple android dans toutes les
langues de radio internationales de
radio canada international voit là bas
et il y aurait plus à vous montrer ce
soit pour la semaine prochaine
évidemment excellent une émission à la
fois c'est là c'est une marque de
commerce ou une émission merci beaucoup
dé bon ce plaisir merci à merci au
revoir tout le monde n'arrive
[Musique]